Oh God oh my god hello everybody my name
is markiplier and welcome to granny this
is the first time I loaded up so I
didn't know that granny who's gonna be
looming over me
okay so this is a horror game where
you're trapped in granny's house I don't
know why no I'm afraid to ask why but
we're gonna we're gonna just go for her
you practice granny is not home
you can explore the house granny moves a
bit slower no creaking floors image
effects quality high let's pump up the
graphics image effects yeah bring him on
air okay
so tip beat quiet she hears everything
keep in mind that if you drop objects on
the floor it creates sound hold the F to
free yourself from bear traps hot under
beds or in cabinets you have five days
use headphones for best experience
get out of there who is this grandpa you
only have five days all you need is in
the house and be quiet she hears
everything and granny is crazy so like
all those horror games that I played in
the bathroom I'm like oh this one it
really is grab on no just high okay just
a lovely walk in the woods am i trying
to doll hey the way I just came from
trying to dig up a body here we're
trying to banish a ghost are we trying
to do something about something I saw
that wait oh did anybody else see that
or am I crazy I'm pretty sure I saw
grandma standing in the woods and okay
alright thanks grandma grandma you
always know how to treat me right
grandma you are just the best you're the
sweetest I love you love you grandma
grandma I love you grandma love you oh
no how am I gonna
okay well at least I get a flashlight
that's always helpful whoo hey so
everything makes noise huh leave this
house oh really
okay did that do anything boom grandma
no no grandma did grandma yes how do I
turn off my flashlight is there even
away grab a balloon listen oh oh god you
got to stop doing that grandma crap Huck
you have to stop doing that okay well oh
okay so that's like the trick I gotta
drop this oh [ __ ] oh oh oh snap I gotta
drop that and she opens that door then I
can get out that's the trick right
that's the trick okay so it's a series
of poses what do you mean what are you
giggling about why you giggling
oh I can't see anything through this
goddamn great because the light won't go
off okay go for it
I wish I could turn this light off
pretty sure she could see where the
lights coming from oh I don't like these
shadows those are fun
those look fun Oh gone all right
grandma no grandma that's jeezum
Stephens that's no good that's no bueno
grandma you gotta stop I've got so much
brain damage I've got so much I can't
think straight
Oh remember my birthday I don't remember
where I was born I'm gonna start
thinking you are my grandma yes I've no
I'm never listen I'm their way I'm just
a grandma like you I have nowhere and
everywhere like you are
did you just unlock another door grandma
did you just unlock another door because
that'd be great that that'd be wonderful
actually if you just unlocked another
door I'd be so happy so happy you there
grandma
I don't trust it I'm gonna wait until
grandma goes downstairs I'm pretty sure
I'll be able to tell when grandma goes
downstairs I'm pretty sure that's
something that's gonna be obvious don't
know what's happening don't know what's
going on okay all right it's been long
enough I guess
I guess I just got to go for it right
not here to go in here okay we're good
close that door okay all right I got a
cogwheel oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh snap part of
a shotgun I can't I can't get out I
can't get out grandma grandma let me out
of this foolish brave Devi's I've got
strawberry jam in my eyes grandma please
please grow I just want to live always
look so good out here grandma
grab a plate please let me go toesies
woozi's we're gonna bout to go toe to
toe in this I'm about to chewy
I'm about to throw down with grandma
it's what I'm saying I'm about to punch
grandma huh I'm about to beat I'm about
to beat grandma nope
sounded like she was laying a bear trap
just nearby which means that she's
probably gonna come patrolling nearby
and see properly which I can't why can't
I tell where she is why is she so tiptoe
quiet why does grandma not make noise
why does grandma I'll get a plus-two to
stealth okay I'm gonna go for it
going off to the right okay there's
another there's another thing in here so
that's good oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
nothing nothing having a pooping I'm
pooping again that map happened grandma
just trying to be honest with you don't
want to come in here it's bad news of
God grandma don't cry much don't
[Laughter]
laughing I love visiting you grandma
grandma please just leave me alone
I know where she went I don't know if
she went downstairs or if she went
somewhere else upstairs I don't know all
I know is that I can't stand up and walk
around cuz it creaks the floorboards my
tippy 10 seas on the would just do
what's waiting up the storm is there
anything in here that I need I don't
think there would be no listen to me
grandma
how would you be able to win okay I'm
gonna do a different strategy here okay
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna drop the
Vaz down over here farther away lap that
there go here then in here and then as
soon as she goes in I'm gonna book it
out of here this is gonna work I say all
of you are doubting me I'm looking it if
there wasn't one of those there I would
have been fine
Oh God oh grandma please granny don't
kiss me don't do that makes me feel
weird
I feel creepy crawly I don't like
Grandma grandma's just the worst
I don't like grandma Oh can I get no
creaking floors just just just just I'm
gonna do this on easy cuz I can't do
anything else
all right day one I've got this I've got
this it's on easy now this should be no
problem
granny ain't gonna get me there's no
creaky floors there's no nothing grandma
ain't gonna get me grandma no go get me
black grandma ain't gonna get me grandma
ain't gonna get me I'm gonna blow my
blast I'm gonna do the same strategy I'm
a blast out of here
slow-ass grandma ain't gonna get me
you have created what you oh there you
are oh there you are I see you go ahead
blasting OH three two one blast
three two one blast three two one
what's that oh I don't know a soup ladle
or something you don't hear nothing
where'd you go granny are you at
where'd you at granny oh what's this
okay we've got something else here mmm
fine fine I fell I fell and I'm dead god
damn it damn it all damn you Hema and
you're trapped
damn you grandma that's clever that's
pretty clever that's that was pretty
clever I gotta leave this place I gotta
get up all right grandma if that is your
real name
I'm peep in my eye hole real near this
I've got my eye papers set on you
oh yeah grandma you think that you're
gonna get away with what you've gotten
away with are you coming over here or
what grandma grandma grandma how about
that a tickle your whistle grandma
shuffling over here with your old creaky
bones
oh yeah grandma yeah that's yeah that's
it yeah that's great that's it grandma
yeah okay all right grandma boughs all
right let's go back up here and list not
fault you know I do you know I love that
game okay so that's a no-go
that's a definitive no-go on that good
to know now I can see where she is I
cannot see where she is I have no idea
oh there she's okay she just went in
there okay so I should be clear to go
downstairs now
yeah yeah oh [ __ ] oh it's fine it's fine
it's just a little little little flesh
wound it ain't nothing
oh that's not a hidey hole okay this is
a broom handle or a shotgun piece I
don't know maybe I can shoot grandma
okay I don't know
eyeball okay nowhere everywhere oh oh
that's not good oh okay so she's not
very fast she's not fast which is good
she's not fast and she's apparently
blind I imagine cuz she lives in the
dark here okay I don't know how to
combine these things so what is this
what's that a picture of Grandma what if
I make a picture of Grandma I'll just
like banish her from existence or
something was that oh good more basement
great more basement got a [ __ ] sublevel
[ __ ] is I didn't do that that was
not me that was definitely definitively
not me you think that you check the
shiny box with a life she is blind she
must be blind she must be blind ooh
she's got to be blind that's got to be
the thing she's blind
okay all right that definitely poked
some holes in my blind theory why how
else would I be able to shine this light
like this oh wow just casually toss that
out of your pants huh a sauna huh
all right yeah sure a sauna okay ooh oh
I can make a shotgun or more do that I
just all [ __ ] okay well okay can't get
rid of you somehow or something
okay it's upside-down anyway it doesn't
matter okay
oh but this here I guess I don't know
what that does I don't know what that
does but I'm assuming that's important
look at this shotgun piece let me go put
this in
I'm gonna build a shotgun i'ma shoot
Grampa
in the face i'ma shoot grandma in the
face I am going to shoot grandma in the
face pretty much okay there's only one
more piece missing she might be coming
down here
she can't be blind she's not blind that
old bat she sees you coming down here
hey grandma uh-oh don't be pooping out
more bear traps I don't know what kind
of thing you got in between your legs I
don't even want to think about that but
it better not be a bear trap machine
because that's just no good that's no
good for anybody not good for me not
good for you not good for the
environment first and foremost which is
what I care about the most
okay so the last shotgun piece might be
in like the upper rooms better okay but
it might be Oh nu nu nu nu nu nu it
might be up in the room said I haven't
gone in yet I'm looking for like
something with a shooty bang device oh
hi grandma oh grandma no listen grandma
no grandma listen listen listen grandma
okay grandma you're fine you're fine
you're fine okay dingaling grandma
you're beautiful and all that jazz
engine part that's not what I'm looking
for a man an engine part really an
engine part this is a big slapping
paddle what am I gonna do with a fricken
slapping paddle I don't know what this
is for
Oh for the car duh it's an engine ding
oh oh
oh hello let me put this in the engine
first oh I'm going in the hall I'm going
in the hole grandma I'm in the hole I
don't know if you can go in the hole - I
don't know okay I don't know what is
this this is my fifth day in the South
she chases me wherever I go I'm quite
injured my body hurts the only thing I
remember before I woke up in this house
is that I was driving in my car suddenly
broke down I went out to see what the
problem was when someone suddenly hit me
in the head I managed to open a pair of
locks on the front door but that's all
why does she do this I hope no one will
experience the same thing as I do if I
do not survive this if someone finds his
message I've noticed that she sometimes
hides things inside fruits Oh in fruits
you say right T right T right as rain
uh-oh
okay what else do I need need a wrench
okay that's fine closing this just in
case I don't know if she's coming down
here but she might so let's be a little
cautious okay I think I've got Grammys
number the problem last time is those
two I was too scared of her right I
needed to be more aggressive I needed I
needed to be out on my way a lot more
than I was this time so I might do that
I'm gonna do exactly that
okay let's go we're gonna go oh she put
that up
Oh boss nice offer very meticulous I'm
gonna go in here I'm gonna see where
this goes I don't know where what is
this oh this isn't good this is not good
this ain't good there's not good this is
not gonna lead anywhere fun is it
oh it's not what what why what oh oh oh
she's got a freaking guillotine what's
in here that I need how many things are
hidden in this game camera ringing this
Bell hopefully she can come out here and
then open up that path that'll be
helpful I don't know what that was I
need another piece of a shotgun so I can
blow granny's head off
[Music]
I need a car key [ __ ]
spark plug in a wrench in a car battery
that's so much stuff there's all this
stuff
ooh steamy nice that feels good oh
grandma
oh are you got to get in the sauna I bet
you are
there's got to be stuff on the first
floor that I haven't seen nowhere okay
grandma please grandma no no I don't
Otley enough no I don't something else
here too yeah the way okay found another
secret passage whoa whoa grandma grandma
listen I mean don't listen don't listen
to a word I say I can't be trusted what
is this me a screwdriver how many tools
are in this goddamn game how is anyone
able to get anything in here
okay what is this the gun the gun the
gun the gun the gun the gun the gun I
get to shoot her
this is gonna work out perfectly I'm
sure I'm just gonna be able to go right
up to her and blammo whammo
just right in there till I'm out of ammo
got the gun that's good okay
shotgun one shot guns loaded all right
grandma Oh grab aah
grandma knocks all over grandma I was
real naughty of me grandma so why don't
you come
discipline me spank me grandma boom
grandma's don't gone for 2 minutes and
30 seconds that's all I get okay what is
this views Oh goddamn it okay I gotta go
I'm gonna reload this that's all I get
that's two minutes and 30 seconds okay
that's grandma is made of some real
durable material but uh like that I
don't like that at all okay grandma
I'm gonna scoot scooch I'm actually I'm
going here because it was still more up
that I could have gone in this weird
house now that I know that's only
temporary that's that's a unfun that's
what I would call unfun um a book that
doesn't help I got a gun no give me the
gun no one give me the goddamn gun
getting behind here yes of course
there's always something hidden behind
those things button ho okay car battery
come on drop this here
go back and get this it's like a doom
Easter Egg level right oh battery right
there let me finish seeing I need a
weapon key I've already got a weapon Oh
what is this
where's this oh wow ooh okay so here's a
picture okay throw that there just don't
want to keep this gun on me you know I
just want to make sure I'm juggling
everything but I got the gun don't worry
about that throw that down there look at
this I'm making a lot of noise I'm aware
but I think my survivability is going up
way high oh the pictures gonna do but uh
I feel I feel good with it so I'm gonna
keep it grandma you want to try me try
me you still knocked out are you still
you up and about
come on just get this painting in
grandma's up grandma's up grandma's up
grandma's up two more pieces maybe oh
grandma listen grandma you don't want it
you don't want to test me you know what
test me breath where'd my Ganga where's
my gun where's my gun no no no grandma
did it clip through the floor something
out grandma no my god oh it's right
there okay we're good
we're all good baby we're all good it's
all good baby it's all good baby baby
he's good baby we're good how can I get
this in here I don't know how to get
this oh that probably was noisy whatever
I'll leave it down here go grab the gun
[Music]
stupid god damn it I was doing so good I
was doing so good
where's my gun gonna be I have no idea
probably where I dropped it all right
here we go take two here we go here we
go baby let's go let's go let's go come
on let's go grab on I'm in a
indeterminate location just come get me
you slowpoke we're not gonna gun it cuz
wow she was did not go far you're going
down the stairs yeah she's going down
the stairs there's also something
sparkly on that bookshelf but I don't
know how to get to that oh you're coming
right back up oh I see you oh I see you
grandma you've creepy lady doing your
weird back in here huh
I am not aware I forgot about that
I should have known I should have known
okay anything in here no anything in
here no here yes what is it
no god you're so quiet why are you so
quiet god dammit why am I so loud god
damn think dammit dammit dammit if I
lose this after doing all this hard work
I'm gonna be so [ __ ] pissed grandma
you ain't go get the best of me grab all
you ain't gonna get the best of me I'm
gonna get the best of me I always do my
best and you're not gonna be any
different
oh I'm not doing so good I'm not doing
so hot I'm not doing so hot everybody
okay go on baby gone goodbye past that
easy not sticking around
I'm just here I don't know what this is
I don't let this goes to some kind of
crankshaft I don't know why more gun
actually that's a good idea I'm just
gonna go get my gun screw this lady key
wait what did it say it was kind of what
does it say [ __ ] play house key
ooh grandma's getting shy and three two
one come Oh feels so bad all right here
we go here's this cool we'll go on to
the playoffs which one led to the
playoffs was this one I think this one
led to the playoffs right right okay
we're gonna get in that playoffs I don't
know what's gonna be at the playoffs but
I hope it's gonna be good for me good
moms let's go baby
oh [ __ ] yeah she's out she's out she's
out for a good little while longer
I got a limp I got quite the limp going
on here oh this is what needed the the
crankshaft to I don't know what that's
for
I have no idea but I know where the
handle is at least did she open this
door did she actually open it damn it
god she didn't so I can't rely on that
but good progress so far I guess now I
know where that's going I suppose okay
where you at grandma oh yeah she's up
where'd you go lady where did you go
okay so that's the crankshaft
winch handle by for the gear mechanism
[ __ ] get loaded locked and loaded
ready to rock what is that
special key Oh interesting and there's a
piece of painting
one piece missing left I'm gonna shoot
her I'll shoot her yet grandma oh yeah
oh yeah come on come on oh yeah come on
we're yeah grandma boom baby hole
ragdoll out of here okay we got a move
we gotta move we gotta move fast okay
special key this goes up in the attic Oh
Joe Torre grandma
so we just got to go up in the attic
then we're gonna put the special key in
out on this recipe he does but yeah does
something what that do open this go
higher I love it I love getting high
highs I can baby okay we got a plate an
empty plate Oh spider a spider you're
telling me you have a pet spider and you
gotta feed it before you can get the
goddamn thing are you kidding me
last day last chance last try here we go
baby it's on baby it's on baby
I've got this we've got this I've got
this
it's got we got it
we're glad we got no she didn't take the
bait again grandma come on come on
grandma grandma grandma's dead I think
grandma's still dead I think grandma is
still actually dead I think bus still
shot where'd you go grandma I miss what
we had
oh I can just go I should have known
that first things first
get the gun
there's the gun reload the gun oh yeah
she's back okay grandma where you be I
don't know how to get past that spider
I'm assuming it requires some kind of
food and Oh baby grandma's down for the
count
what is this oh that's nothing was this
I haven't been here yet there's nothing
here I'm gonna load I'm gonna load this
the grandma extinguisher okay we got two
more bullets left one up here and one
down there but I'm gonna load that but
I'm also gonna take this and I'm gonna
go outside and I'm gonna put this on the
thing and then I'll just need a gear I
think for it I think this is for that I
don't know what this is for in the long
run there seems to be a lot of puzzles
here and not a lot of answers but for
now this is this is the what this before
I'm pretty sure yeah okay I don't know
why that's there something's missing
here well I'm pretty sure this is part
of that wishing well oh wait no
ah the well I didn't even see the well
before but uh that would make a lot more
sense okay so if there's got to be
something here yes yes yes yes yes yes
what we yes take your time please no
rush
what is it it's a gear oh okay
well that's easy all right then
easy-peasy no no don't do that
I don't know if grandma's sleeping yet
okay just need one more gear I don't
know where that would be
but it's need one more
Oh what the hell whoa whoa whoa there
grandma that's where you spawn cuz
that's no good no good that's no good
what is that up there there's something
up there I don't know how to get to it
how do I get to you I don't I get to you
there's no jump it's not liking maybe I
throw something up at it yeah I don't
know how to get to that one okay but as
far as everything else goes I'm at a bit
of a loss as to where I go cuz there's
no real food or anything that I can put
on them that plate oh dear never mind
all right good enough for me okay gear
pop Oh master key sick sick dude sick oh
hell oh it didn't work on that though
that's it's a master key but it doesn't
work on everything it's only a master
key it's whatever you know it's whatever
why does grandma create traps like this
by the way I just wanted to ask that so
no is this gonna work on the car oh wait
what's the point of having a master key
what's the point what's even the point
how about here need a padlock key this
doesn't even [ __ ] work on everything
it doesn't this is not a master key
that's not our master keys work stupid
key there's no point to you you're just
a big lie oh you're just a lie oh wait a
minute last picture I think last picture
oh please don't spawn please don't spawn
right while I'm down here please don't
spawn right while I'm down here
grandma is awarded you with a bonus day
in the house I don't want a bonus day in
the house I don't want to be here a
bonus day meat meat meat me too me too
me too me too me meat if I put this meat
on the spider plate then
also this can move there's something in
here I don't know what but I'm not going
for yet because I've got meat and if
meat is what I think meat is and I can
put this right here
spider go get it oh yes oh yes and then
what's in here yeah I do you know I do
baby
you know and this padlock key what's in
here
what is this where does this go oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay I got the padlock key whatever
good that does it's not gonna do a lot
of good but I got it so this can open
that but I don't know how many other
things are there possibly to open in
this game let's look in this place real
whoa more shotgun shells
tons of shotgun shells alright that's
good
it was the path here that I unlocked but
I don't think there's I don't have the
screwdriver or anything like that so I
can't exactly whoa oops oh that's not
good good okay
okay there's grandma I have an idea
where's the gun where's the gun there's
the gun okay
there's the gun well let me use [ __ ] let
me use this on that we'll get the gun
okay get the gun
whatever grandma hey grandma hey you
stupid you stupid lady she tries to put
stuff back up I'm ruining your house
number one I'm gonna shoot her first and
foremost gonna show holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
number two this might be a waste of a
bullet but number two oh come on oh come
on oh come on oh come on oh come on
you dick you dick okay oh [ __ ] oh there
goes there goes okay that's good okay
now this is loaded up and ready to go so
the screwdriver I can use this on
the the screwdriver panel the only thing
that I saw that needed a screwdriver was
in here why is this book something that
I can use I don't know it doesn't matter
okay and then this can unlock nothing
here where was it get right here right
here boom boom done what is that safe
key safe key now I go get this safe for
some reason and then something's gonna
be in the safe and then the safe will
help me somehow probably and then this
has wire Clippers
I think cutting pliers all right so my
cousin cutting pliers here I don't know
why I would that's not a wrench
somewhere I need a wrench maybe like for
the front door or something like that
please don't spawn don't spawn don't
spawn don't spawn okay fine cutting
pliers here oh there we go need the
master key oh the master key is for that
okay that's good where did I leave the
master key I don't even remember where I
left the master key [ __ ] dick [ __ ] [ __ ]
where's the master key that blue ones
the padlock key the red ones the master
key I must have left it up yeah here it
is
okay master key use this oh okay I'll
leave it right here can't use it yet but
I got it take this anything in the tub
no anything under the tub no oh oh [ __ ]
no you don't good god you sneaky lady
you sneaky lady you think you can just
sneak up on me like that you are wrong
you're wrong grandma you're wrong is
that there's something that can be taken
down with a hammer I know that
I'm out of bullets up here Oh hammer
okay
hammer whoa what was it that could be
taken down with a hammer I think it was
upstairs hammer for wood panels upstairs
right here okay easy as that
we're in it's still suspecting something
okay baby thing very creepy
kid what is this for car key okay great
I didn't want the car key I don't even
have anything for the car God god damn
you
okay is there there's no way to go over
there maybe I can use one of the planks
ooh
smart smart after place is that all I
needed
okay good good good good great great
great great what's over here
grim god damn it
oh god damn it oh god damn it oh you
piece of [ __ ] oh you [ __ ] I was on
[ __ ] oh oh well that sure was easy okay
well that's not gonna help me if she's
gonna spawn in two seconds I need
cutting pliers in the hammer again so
the hammer I just left it here she's
coming initiative
it's a prod comment yeah she's
definitely gonna be coming okay womp
okay I'm gonna assume that she's on the
way I don't like this I hate this
actually duck in here
okay so I need to bring the cutting
pliers back up get the wrench out of
there fix up the car get the car keyed
downstairs I need to get that other
bullet shoot that lady in the face she's
not here is she
oh [ __ ] I don't know where she is I
might go for it I'll drop off this
where's the cutting pliers they were
right here
I had the cutting pliers right here both
keys are right here cutting pliers
perfect okay that was loud huh no ah
shitty dicks
okay shitty dicks are you're gonna
you're gonna play ring around the rosies
with my woes ease it's fine this is easy
it's Easy Street [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] it's fine she's
gonna lose interest
real quick she's gonna lose interest
watch this three two one interest gone
she's gone it's all gone easy-peasy
okay okay so I'm gonna drop that no I'm
gonna drop that down I'm gonna drop it
down grab the car key drop it down [ __ ]
I didn't drop either of them down Oh
oh I got a bonus day oh I got a bonus
day Oh bonus day that's right I got a
bonus day okay all right bonus day all
right bonus day that's all good bonus
day get where's grandma not here that's
okay I think the key fell down so I
think we're oh [ __ ] she's coming okay
I'm just gonna hide I'm gonna play a
real safe real safe I've got there's one
more bullet in the basement for the gun
oh but I don't have spark plugs for the
car I don't know what else I would need
for the boards maybe I need the hammer
for the one last board on the door maybe
I could get out maybe I could get out
pretty soon I may be able to get out
pretty soon where is she
there she is need a hammer okay
hammer do that okay easy wrench back up
can I get have whoo [ __ ] can I get out
can I just go oh no no I was so god damn
it okay [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that's so close
I'm gonna go for it again
and I'm gonna gun it cuz I know where
things are I know what to do I think I
can get out I mean things are gonna be
different in different places but I
think I can make it I know how to beat
grandma shoot her in the face it's gonna
take a bit but I'm just gonna gun
through it I think I can make this I
don't want to leave this on a loos like
that I don't want to take that oh I know
I can beat this I know I can beat it
guys I know I can't this is the first
time I've seen a fruit so that's good
I've got that going for me can I cut
this with this yes I can chunk alright
what was this again padlock key okay so
I got the padlock key that's good
alright that's good I feel good about
that
yeah oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] she's coming oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
jump in jump in don't don't don't don't
oh wow
but now she's unlocked that one so I got
away back shoot you oh she did lock it
did
is that open Abul goddamnit of course
you did oh ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho how
did you get up here whoa whoa I didn't
know you could get here oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] everything's in
a different place than it was which is
cool cuz it's all randomly generated but
it's real dickish cuz I don't know where
I'm going
let's go ahead and get the padlock done
done okay easy peasy I have an idea I
don't know how good it is but I have an
idea
there's a teddy bear in here and I
haven't seen many items that are
completely useless in this game
so I'm gonna um I have an idea - um okay
so I got an idea with this teddy bear
that's mysteriously beating like a heart
like he's got a heartbeat to put it in
the guillotine which probably now that
it's got a heartbeat probably not the
best idea I've ever had oh oh oh [ __ ] oh
okay so I'm gonna wait till she goes
away and I think grab it again oh [ __ ]
there she is oh [ __ ] she doesn't like
this she doesn't like this
she don't like her eyes are red Oh her
eyes are red Oh her eyes are red Oh her
eyes are red I'm gonna drop it out there
I'm gonna drop it out there for later
for later for later she does not like
you touching that teddy bear she does
not like that oh she is not about you
touching that teddy bear I'm thinking
that if I could get a I can get a shot
at cutting that teddy bears head off
then I am gonna be either in big trouble
or it's gonna be alright
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god
oh my god
why was she right there why was she
right there that that's not fair why was
she there that was too close
that was too close that was too close
that was too close
weapon key I've never seen the weapon
key before but uh it's the every time
every time every time so that's now open
but I have to go get the meat let me go
see what kind of weapon the weapon key
unleashes cuz the lockers right here
what do we got baby
Oh Oh tranquilizer darts
hey grandma grandma hey granny
oh oh oh he's now gone for two minutes
she is gone oh you can reload them oh
that's handy oh that's handy Danny let
me try to back they try to shoot this
thing with this hey there we go got the
screwdriver which is good okay good this
is all good all going real good let me
drop this here grab the meat go upstairs
real quick take care of the spider
whatever is in the spider area that's
what I'm gonna go get and three two you
want spider yeah hate you okay gasps wow
this is what I came down here to get
this is the heart not even worth it not
even worth of trouble wonder if I can
cut the head off of the thing Walla
Walla granny is incapacitated okay I got
the fruit that was in here so that's
good I'm just gonna drop this by the
drop this by that I grab this I'm gonna
go take care of the screwdriver thing it
was a car key God everything for the car
I don't need the car key I don't care
about the car the car doesn't do me any
good
does it maybe it does maybe it does do
me some good
maybe he does I don't know oh [ __ ] she's
back oh [ __ ] holy [ __ ] she's back
okay she's back with a vengeance no
where'd I put the padlock yeah I don't
need that where'd I put the whoa oh okay
granny okay where did I put the I put it
by the meat that's right it's by the
meat okay so I just got to go get
tranquilizer okay is there is it empty
or something it's empty isn't it okay
it's empty that's okay I'm gonna pick it
right up and i'ma shoot granny oh no
that's so nice that it's reloadable this
is like the greatest thing this is the
greatest thing I've ever seen okay um ow
[ __ ] every time what do I have and
what do we need okay there's a it really
seems to be emphasizing the car stuff
but I'm not worried about the car stuff
right now whoa what is that whoa whoa
whoa weird weird weird weird put
something here there's like a book I got
a book maybe we could put a book there
for all that looks like something that
you could put a book on it's the only
other thing that I know that is kind of
like that it's a book you know the books
not here that was last time goddamn ooh
what is that safe key all right I'll
take the safe key engine god it's
everything for the stupid car maybe the
car is the way that I gotta get out this
time I don't know oh hey the Bears back
that's funny
okay let me look closely and here again
master keys right there that's right
there's the book okay there's the book
let me try that let me see what the book
will do okay come here come here come
here come here grandma Oh
Oh oh my stars ooh
okay grandma's gone for two minutes so
says you but if I grab this book uh I
hate that it's not near the tranquilizer
can we reload my grandma where'd you put
it
could you put it grandma where to put it
grandma there it is okay
so imma drop this here put it up here
okay so if I put this over here oh yeah
maybe this goes here
holy [ __ ] oh my god
what the [ __ ] is that what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is that what is that oh oh god
damn it what is that I have no idea what
that is I mean it seems like that might
be granny's quote-unquote corpse like uh
maybe her real body
maybe if I kill the Hat and it for good
maybe let me try shooting some at it
maybe that'll do some a pride do some
right god damn it
nope blink nope okay
this nope boink okay good thing that
says unlimited tranquilizer in it
there's something a piano underground a
cage and a spider I don't know is weird
whatever it is
whoa whoa whoa what the [ __ ]
whoa whoa I didn't know that was a thing
whoa whoa whoa interesting [ __ ]
interesting I didn't know that was a
thing
ooh okay there was something in those
there was something in here but the
winch okay I can use this for getting
the thing out of the thing and
apparently there's a faster way now as
opposed to going down here ah then she
should be gone long enough to do this
just fine well do the hammer
okay the hammer cool that's good that's
useful hammer all right let's do the
hammer stuff learn what the Hammers
gonna get me I like hammer hammer is
real cool now the question is do I have
to fall no I don't good good I was
hoping not okay what did we get in here
cutters that's perfect we need the
cutters yay okay and that's the last the
hammer I think and the cutters
Oh No you didn't see nothing okay
grandma that's right that's right you
never see nothing cuz you're blind as a
bat
easy grab this and go sparkplugs I guess
it is a car escape for me huh alright
then
well now I got to go get the battery and
put that down there and then they get
the gas and [ __ ] but then the wrench is
easy cuz it's in the main area maybe
this is the way it wants me to go maybe
this is the way I'm gonna go maybe the
car is it alright car escape it is spark
plugs need a wrench okay oh yeah where's
the where's the UH where's the gun grab
that you heard that huh
funny huh we'll see what's funny who's
laughing now lady
it's NUMMI all right in the vag sorry
excuse me grandma oh come on
Oh grandma grandma thank you okay drop
this here take this
I guess I'll drop it down there whatever
toss granny's corpse down there too
I'm gonna take this wrench and then I'm
gonna get the master key as well I'm
gonna drop it all down this way down
there go get the master key which is in
the microwave of all places no did I
need the padlock key I'm on a need of
the padlock key I can't remember which
one it was might have been the padlock
key either way I'm gonna grab all of
them just in case and then the car
battery is in the back area somewhere so
is it the master key Yes No maybe so it
is the padlock key of course it is gasps
dunk into the gas tank
easy peasy grab the wrench easel Pazuzu
da da and then the battery and then this
is good to go
you should be just in time to tranq
grandma grandma you need your medicine
grandma
now come on grandma don't skip your dose
you know you need your dosage come on
you need your sleepy time medicine oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] I know
oh I'm sorry gram can I have that back
thanks grandma
all right good boy got that take the car
battery and then I think we out II I
think we I think we out he we might be
Audi we we might actually be Audi I I
don't know for sure but we might be Audi
or whatever car brand this car is anyway
let's get out of here
yeah maybe so open her up all right Oh
No
Oh baby
whoa oh [ __ ] um I think it must be like
that it must be like one if I could have
gotten out the front door I guess I had
all the tools necessary but the car
that's more stylish baby that's more
stylish so that was granny that was
great I loved that it looked very
simplistic but it had good mechanics in
there kind of like two ways going out
there and you have to go through the
whole house and you got to find all
these puzzles it was very much like
escape room style games but in a 3d
sense and it had a very good execution
of a graham he was scary the whole way
through granny was scared granny was
always a threat so that made it really
cool I learned but it was fun and I only
beat it uneasy but it was still fun so
thank you everybody so much for watching
you can find this game through the link
in the description below check out the
other scary games that I've done I've
done hundreds of them there's a whole
playlist of them check them all out
scary games as far as the eye can see so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]